morning welcome to westminster for our
live q a with the health secretary matt
hancock lovely to see you good to be
here
thank you over the next 30 minutes or so
we'll be putting questions from you
our viewers to him about the coronavirus
the uk has now recorded
the most deaths in europe and is the
second worst hit country in the world
and covid19 has left us living in
lockdown for weeks and weeks
and weeks what does the future hold and
will we beat it thousands of you have
sent in questions literally thousands
health secretary i have to tell you
uh we'll be asking the man who's been
leading us through this crisis
and uh asking um about what we need to
do
about coronavirus he himself of course
has fallen victim to it
to answer some of them he's here in just
a moment
yesterday the prime minister announced
the most radical steps yet
to slow the spread of this virus these
steps
are not requests they are rules
as a human being what are you most
worried about at the moment mr hancock
oh well what there's so many things upon
medical advice
i was tested and that test has been
positive so i'll be self-isolating
i am now setting the goal of 100
000 tests per day by the end of
this month
the opening of the 4 000 bed nhs
nightingale hospital
i pay tribute to everybody involved in
putting this together
in nine days tracking and tracing
will allow us to get our down and hold
our down if you're watching this
and you live on the isle of wight i have
a
simple message download the app to
protect the nhs
and save lives
[Music]
and from when we told you that we were
going to pose questions on your behalf
to the health sector we've had literally
thousands of you wanting
to take part so let's press on and get
through as many as we can health
secretary if you wouldn't mind let's
start
uh with uh neil uh forgive me doug
mclaren who wants to ask about neil
ferguson uh and this is uh what he's
saying has neil ferguson been fined by
the police for breaking lockdown rules
and if not
why not the answer to that is i don't
know doug
um the first i heard about this was when
i read it
in the newspapers it's not a story i've
been close to
but clearly the the social distancing
rules are there for everyone
and they're incredibly important and
they're deadly serious
and the reason is because they're the
means by which
we've managed to get control of this
virus
should he be prosecuted well that you
can imagine what my views are but that
is
absolutely important it's a matter for
the police as a government minister
i'm not allowed to get involved in the
operational decisions of police matters
but i i i i think that you know the
social distancing rules are
very important and people should follow
them i mean we saw what happened with
the scottish uh chief medical officer
didn't mean catherine caldwell and she
was warned by the police
right um was that the right decision
well i
i absolutely i back the police uh back
the scottish police and i'd uh back the
police here they'll take their decisions
independently from
ministers that's quite right it's always
been like that and that's why
even though i've got a clear answer to
what i think uh it's
as a as a minister the way we run the
police is that they make decisions like
this
so i give them their space to make that
decision uh but i think
he took the right decision to resign
well you said you read it in the papers
i mean what did you think when you read
it did you bang your head on the desk
well it's
just it it's extraordinary and um
you know i i
i don't understand speechless i i am
that doesn't often happen to me okay
i know and um but i am i
i am and you know uh mr ferguson is a
professor ferguson is a very very
eminent and impressive scientist
uh and um his the science that he's done
has been an important part of what we've
listened to
uh and um i think that it's a
uh uh you know i think that he took the
right decision
you wouldn't have to resign yeah you
wouldn't have thought to keep him
it's just not that's just not possible
in these circumstances final thought
just before we move on to the next
question i mean
one of his defenses was that uh he'd
already had coveted
like you so as a result it's okay to
social justice you know what i asked
exactly that question of the chief
medical officer after
i'd had um coronavirus and
there is normally normally there's
immunity
and you're much lower risk from a
coronavirus if you've had it recently
but we don't know that for sure and
there's so many new things about this
coronavirus
that we don't know that that's the case
so i asked exactly that question of the
chief medical officer can i behave
differently because i've now had it
um do i still have to do the social
distancing and the answer was very clear
which is yes we all have to abide by
social distancing now
as it happens we do have this a survey a
scientific survey
in the field right now to find out
if people who have definitely had it
because they tested positive
and have the antibodies if they then get
it again
and if they don't then we'll know
scientifically
that for people who have had it and have
been tested to have the
antibodies that they can go about um
in a much more low risk way and if if
that science comes through
as we do expect it to um then we will be
able to
say that people are lower risk if
they've um if they've had that positive
antibody test but we don't know that yet
and that's why the rules are the same
and if that proves to be the case
can he have his job back everybody's got
to follow the social distancing rules
okay our next question is from linda
from whitwell who
which is in derbyshire and it's a video
this is
what linda wants to ask you i am one of
the
very vulnerable patients who is being
shielded
am i going to have to wait until a
vaccine has been developed
before i can hook my children and
grandchildren
and see my friends or are there any
other options being considered to
guarantee
my safety outside lockdown
secretary well thank you that's a really
important question i know it's a
question a lot of people are asking
now um the those who are shielded
are those just to be clear are those
who've specifically received a letter
from the nhs saying that they are
clinically extremely vulnerable to this
disease
this is not uh the the rules for
the all over 70s which are in a who are
in a different category
so this the answer i'm going to give
relates to the shielded who've
specifically received
a letter from the nhs and i want to make
it clear because there has been some
um uh confusion between those two groups
and the answer is that we asked those
who are being shielded
to stay to avoid as much
human contact as possible for 12 weeks
that we may have to extend that 12 weeks
but we hope not to
and the answer is is we we may well be
able to release
some of those measures before a vaccine
is
available um if we can get the level of
new cases the number of new cases
right down so in some countries they've
managed to
now get the number of new cases right
down
and that that if we get there if we
succeed in doing that
then we will be able to um
take clinical advice on whether it's
safe for those who are shielded to be
able to for instance
hug their grandchildren i understand the
the emotional
impact that this is having and there are
many people who haven't left their homes
now for uh for six weeks or so that is a
long long time
especially if you don't have a garden
and so that's
right at the front of my mind uh and
um and and making sure we get the rules
around
though those who are shielded right is
really important
um and we we will take into account not
just the impact of coronavirus but also
the wider impact on people's physical
and mental health from being stuck at
home for such a long time what about if
they managed to squeeze in a
cheeky uh hug with their grandchildren
would they
in your views still be treated in the
same way as neil ferguson
well everybody should follow the social
distancing guidelines
however what i'd say is that those who
are shielded they're shielded for their
own protection and of course we all must
follow the
social distancing guidelines for the
protection of public health
but the specifically very um
strenuous rules for those who are
shielded
offer their protection um in a
over and above the the broader social
distancing rules that we must all follow
okay let's uh listen to
uh brian this is uh brian's uh question
what if a vaccine can't be found for
covid
19 is what brian's asking well if a
vaccine can't be found then we
have to learn to find a way to
live with this virus which means getting
the numbers
right down and then holding them down
through for instance
mass scale testing the and tracing the
virus through a combination of the
technology and human contact traces
and of course we're working on
treatments
that is to say drugs that can
make sure that if you do get ill with
coronavirus
it isn't life-threatening in the way
that it is now it's not a guarantee
we'll find it but none of these
it is not a guarantee we'll find a
vaccine with we're doing everything we
possibly can
uh that we're putting as many resources
into the
the scientists brilliant scientists who
are who are leading this
the uk has two of the two of the top 10
uh projects in the world in fact three
um
uh uh there's one new one coming along
from
uh black so smith cline and sanofi
so this we've got three potential
vaccines two of which are really two of
the world leaders
but we're working with countries around
the world so that whoever
develops a first successful and safe
vaccine will be able to okay we're lucky
to have you and to get through as many
questions
as possible as i said we've had many
thousands this
is uh from ryan it's a video about the
two meter rule
oh yeah we wouldn't be able to operate
in them
in that situation we've got such a small
calf
we wouldn't be able to get people in um
that's our big worry
our restaurant's gonna have to go back
to work in these circumstances or
can we still stay closed until these
restrictions are eased
and get forceable from the government uh
he represents so many of the questions
we've been asked
yeah so this is another really important
question
and and the business secretary is
working on the rules
for safe working so that we can try to
when we get the rate of new infections
down
we can work on how people can get back
to
work as safely as possible and we're
going to
say more about that very shortly
reduce that distance because some
countries it's like a meter and a half
isn't it not two meters
well that the the two-meter rule is
based on
the best scientific advice and the
problem is the more you reduce it
the more easily the virus spreads
and it isn't just it isn't linear in
that if you halve it you don't just
double the likelihood of
uh increasing of the virus spreading you
you increase it exponentially so
we're very um careful to follow the
clinical advice on the two meter rule
but of course um you know
there's also very strong evidence that
outdoors
the spread is much much lower so there
may be workarounds that
some businesses for instance cafes
especially over the summer might be able
to put in place
okay um there are of course other
illnesses that people
are being dogged by at the moment not
just corona virus and
many people feel that they are being
left out not least cancer patients and
this
is from um joe and this is what joe
is saying why is the excel center in
east london not being used as the
epicenter of covid19 freeing up hospital
space and making it safe
for other serious illness treatments so
take the 19 people
to the nightingale that you've just shut
down and then other people can be
treated
uh better in their um environment well
we
we we're taking this principle um beca
which is very
um a sensible principle and putting that
into into place within existing
hospitals
within the mainstream hospitals um and
the reason for that
is that many people with coronavirus
also have other conditions and the excel
center the nightingales are designed for
people who
only have coronavirus and don't have
other underlying health conditions
and we now thankfully the numbers who
are
in our uh intensive care
awards are are much lower they're about
half what they were
at the peak around easter yeah but joe's
point is why not put them all together
in the nightingale so what we're doing
is within hospitals
we're separating the hospitals into
covert and non-covered areas and that
means that if some if people have
more serious complications they're
actually safer in a
full-blown hospital that has the full
intensive care
capabilities so we've we have looked at
this question
and because the numbers in hospital are
now coming down we're able to support
people within the
within within to the mainstream
hospitals
the facilities are better in the main
hospitals that's right absolutely
because the nightingale
is there the nightingales are there to
treat only coronavirus
many people with coronavirus who are in
intensive care also have other
complications
that that the nightingale wouldn't be as
well placed
to deal with so it is in fact it's safer
if you've got coronavirus to be treated
in a mainstream hospital
but also we are separating out within
hospitals
the coronavirus from the non-coronavirus
areas
to reduce the spread of the disease
within hospitals so nightingale is there
as extremists really
it is there for for to stop it was there
to stop the nhs being overtopped and you
know one of the good things that's
happened in this crisis is that the nhs
has always been able to
have the capacity we haven't had the
situation we've seen in other countries
where the the health system's been
overwhelmed yeah but just to answer joe
i mean you know cancer patients are
still going to have to wait
longer than normal so we're restarting
cancer treatment
um there is a challenge with some cancer
treatments when it takes your immune
system right down to zero
that that is not a wise thing to do
in the when there's when the when
there's an
epidemic going on that's irrespective of
the
what's there what's available in the nhs
um
but a lot of cancer treatment has
carried on through
the the crisis of course because it's
time critical
uh and those parts that we stopped
for less time critical cancers no no
cancer is not time critical but for the
less time critical cancers
we're now beginning to restart and doing
that in a safe way
the absolutely critical message for
viewers is that
if you are advised by your clinician to
go to a hospital appointment
you should go because they will have
taken into account
the the the covered risks as well as
the risk of uh so there will have been
that risk assessment and you should keep
you you really should follow the advice
if you're told to go to hospital please
do
um doctors uh are of course are taking
uh
precautions as far as ppe is concerned
dentists
that's a big issue uh dentist
appointments uh something people are
having to uh cope
without at the moment a question for you
here from dr akoya
patients are in pain dangerous swellings
primary dental care is in danger of
collapse because
private practices who supports the
nhs with up to 60 of funding
have had no help from the government no
rates relief
no grants and things are in danger of
collapse
what are you going to do about it so
dentistry is a another really important
area that we want to get
started again as soon as it's safe to do
so so
there have been uh arrangements put in
place for emergency dental care
so for patients who've got a something
urgent
there are almost 200 centers around the
uk
around england that say that for
emergency dental care but we have
advised people not to
take up routine dental checkups in fact
i had to delay mine and
that is that was a obviously as a
an important precaution because by its
nature
that your dentist is close to you when
they're looking at your teeth
um and i'm working with the british
dental association
i understand the impact because many
people pay privately to go to the
dentist
and that of course is having a business
impact on on dentists
alongside the lack of nhs work because
we're not recommending people go for
routine checkups
so it is something that uh it's it's
really important that we support our
dentists through this
through this period it'll be open again
as part of the restart of the nhs that's
something that we're working on
um weeks a month i i hope in that sort
of time period yes
so you'll be able to go yeah but i can't
give a concrete answer because it
depends on again it depends on the rate
of the new transmissions of the virus
coming
down so that which makes things safer
right across the board
and but i i very much hope then that you
realize how original i i do i get it i
get it
okay um fertility treatment um is
something um
i i know you've spoken about actually uh
in downing street when you were doing
one of the news conferences it's
something that carla from the forest of
dean was
going through before lockdown
and this is what uh carla says can there
be
some guidance on when cancelled
operations due to kovid 19 would be
rebooked as a woman of 34
severe fertility issues it's absolutely
still destroying
knowing each day i am waiting my chances
of becoming a mother
are just slipping by yes well
heartbreaking
it is heartbreaking and you know it's
something that
i've seen the wonders of ivf uh in
my own family um not me personally but
uh close family and um
and so i know how important it is for
you carla
and for other people in your
circumstances
um i've i'm really pleased that we have
been able to restart
fertility treatment we announced that
last week now
of course fertility treatment was paused
for
just over a month and therefore there
will be a um
there will be a backlog to get through
but we've been able to get that restart
going
and i very much hope carla that you get
your appointment
sooner rather than later because i of
course i understand how
how urgent it is for for people who want
to start a family and
and also how wonderful it is when it
goes right sure the medics that are
involved with ppe they would still
with uh ivf forgive me they were too
many acronyms and they would still get
the ppe as necessary would they yes of
course it's important
um follow and that they get the ppe
that is required uh by the guidance
that's been set out
okay yeah um the next question is from
john
in edinburgh who is asking about
care homes did you sacrifice
the elderly people in care homes
so you could ensure that the nhs were
not overrun
um no we didn't we didn't do this um
you can understand the question you can
understand why people feel that way
um well what i'd say is that
we've from the start worked very hard to
protect people in care homes um and
actually the um
you know the proportion of people why do
you think they feel that you didn't
well i i i i don't know i think that
there hasn't been as much
until this crisis there hasn't
historically been as much
um discussion in the public debate about
the support that is given to people in
care homes
and i'm really glad that actually one of
the things that's happened as we go
through this crisis
is that there has been much more
discussion of that um we put in place
the first guidance to
care homes in february and when
large numbers of people were left
hospital to create the space in the
hospital to deal with covert 19 that was
before
there was a there were many cases of
coronavirus
um and then since then we've put in
place the rules
that are in place in england at least
for testing everybody as they leave
hospital to go into care homes
um well the problem was that we the
testing didn't exist and we had to build
that testing capacity as has been a
you know subject of widespread
discussion so it wasn't as if it was a
mistake it was just that you didn't have
the capacity
the testing capacity didn't exist in
this country um
and we've had to build that throughout
the throughout the crisis
what would you do differently as far as
care homes are concerned
well i think it's i think it's very hard
because
i i feel like we put a huge amount of um
of effort and resources behind
supporting care homes
from the start um maybe we should have
uh explained that more clearly
and i think that there's a um
the the the challenge with um care homes
in this crisis is that of course
many of the most vulnerable people
vulnerable to coronavirus because it
hits
older people much harder are in care
homes so by their nature
um they are some of the most vulnerable
areas but you feel that you protected
them as
as well as i feel like they're the
testing there will be a there's a
there's a time for going over the
history of this
but now the most important thing is that
we get
the as we protect people in cams as much
as possible including using the new
testing
to um to make sure that we protect
people in kms as much as possible
and you wish you could have had that
testing earlier it would have been
wonderful if we'd gone into this crisis
with a
with a global scale diagnostics industry
yes
um but you know in in the way that for
instance germany did
but we went in more like other countries
like france
which similarly have had to build the
testing capability um
from almost from scratch and
now we're able to have those tests and
the asymptomatic tests
we weren't before not by a lack of
effort by the people who work on my team
who've been absolutely amazing on this
but because we just didn't have that
capacity as a country
okay um this next question is from
another young viewer and that
is um james he's 16 and he has autism he
wants to know
there he is he wants to know when he can
go back to school this is what he said
i miss college i miss my friends
please can you give us a clear answer
when we when i when i will return to
college
and how will education recover after
when this
coronavirus pandemic is over please
what would you say to people like james
well we
didn't want to shut schools and colleges
but we had to
because all that because i mean other
countries didn't yeah we really did
yeah why because although um
children don't suffer
from the from the consequences of
coronavirus
nearly as much as adults there have been
some a small number of very sad cases
but by and large children are not
affected by the disease don't
go down with anything they still spread
it
and that means that um the colleges
and schools are a place where lots of
people from different households the
children come and mix
and that that proved to be a real
spreader
um so the colleges and schools were
perfectly safe for the children but they
it helped to spread the disease
now we're considering now how we can get
that restarted
in a safe way when it's right to do so
but what is it
well it's too soon and and i know it's
frustrating and i
i heard that it's watching at home
tearing their hair out
aren't they they're saying oh i'm doing
my i'm doing the home schooling as best
i can i know
i need to get it back to you look i have
three children who are currently home
homeschooling and i'm not able to help
with that very much
uh but my wife is and she has to put a
huge amount of effort into it as well
and we know that it's imperfect i mean
thanks to technology at least it's
better than it might have been
in the past um but that's you know it's
no
it i totally understand the frustration
of those who want to get back to school
in fact i
admire um children who want to get back
to school
um because of the um because they want
the social media as well we're looking
at september in all seriousness
well we've just you know it is just so
important that for all the reasons that
we've been discussing
that we get the rate of new
transmissions of the disease down
um and if there is something that we can
do before then
uh then then we will but i can't make
any promises on the horizon isn't it
start as a new term that's probably
in all seriousness i know you know it's
tempting to give concrete answers but
the problem viewers just want something
that that's the doctor of course i do
and i think and
uh what i'm i'm not you know dodging the
question i'm answering really directly
we don't know
and we don't know because we've got to
see the progress of the disease and we
don't know how people are going to
um behave um in terms of
uh in terms of the lockdown measures
which are the thing that's having the
biggest impact on getting the disease
right
so i so i understand the frustration of
people wanting to know the answer you
know will it be june will it be
september
you know for what for what age groups as
well because uh
there's other countries have taken
different decisions for different age
groups
um and um and and it would be really
uh i could you know i'm tempted to
prejudge those decisions but we just
don't yet have the data
but we're i think we're coming to a
position when we
relatively soon we might be able to i
hope so i hope so yeah
so i'm very sorry that i haven't been
able to directly answer your question
it's not because i don't want to
it's because it wouldn't be responsible
of me too what are you good at teaching
for at home when you do the
homeschooling what's your subject
i'm terrible at it i'd be a terrible i i
i'm
terrible at it i'm um i'm not very
patient
six twelve and thirteen okay so you do a
bit of politics with them oh
no lots of discussion about politics
yeah yeah lots of that
lots of history yeah lots of discussions
of history
um actually the thing i like teaching
most is maths i really yeah because i
like the
i like the uh the the clarity of math
especially at that age
when i can understand it and the um you
know the clarity of teaching maths is
uh okay when lockdown finishes remind me
not to go to the pub with you
a question from john fletcher
who is in uh ryegate uh here we go hi
john
can it really be just a coincidence that
the virus originated in a city where
there are two
laboratories researching coronavirus
well uh we have looked into this and we
don't have any
evidence that this american study well
they
there's there isn't evidence that this
is a man-made
coronavirus um and um
there's a and so i haven't i understand
the um
what uh john's getting at but uh we
haven't seen any evidence of that link
okay have the americans shared any
evidence with us
at all because we heard from the
president didn't we and he said that
there is a link
um the president um
phrase tiptoeing through the raindrops
here he phrased his comments very
carefully
uh we haven't seen any evidence of a
link
and so there's nothing that i've seen
that confirms the
uh the the the discussion the allegation
that john's referring to that i know is
is something that people are talking
about what if it turns out
that it was from one of these labs
that's a whole new discussion with china
then isn't it
yes i mean there's so many what-ifs
about this disease and there's so much
to learn
to you know afterwards when we look at
how it was handled
uh to make sure that we're more prepared
in future i mean one of the things
is um is you know at some point
the evidence appears to be that the
disease jumped from
an animal to a human and trying to make
sure that we stop that happening again
that is
that is in the global interest it's not
just a matter for one country
uh that's a uh that's it
came out of a lab and it's literally
caused
havoc right around the world and the
chinese have got some serious questions
to answer
well you're tempting me into a
hypothetical uh answer but well not
according to the americans
well if you let's um let's
let's look at the actual evidence and i
haven't seen any evidence of that
um have you asked for it from the
americans um well
look of course i am interested in where
this
came from but i'm actually more
interested in how we get the country
back in a beat so we've asked them and
we'll wait to see what they say donald
trump um
uh rated his performance during the
pandemic
as a 10 out of 10 this from stuart how
would you
rate your own performance well stuart i
would say that i'm constantly trying to
learn you know and constantly trying to
understand what's gone well and what can
be improved
and you know there are some things that
we've had to change because
it didn't work first time round and um
so i'm you know i don't i'm i think
i think i think um i'd i'd i'd give you
a more
um humble response than the president so
you're an eight
well i'm not going to put a figure on it
obviously but um
the uh but but there are things that
we've learned yeah i'll give you one
example of something that we
we learned and we changed um we put in
place guidance around funerals
and that guidance was interpreted in a
different way
to what we expected and then i saw some
funerals were taking place with no loved
ones nearby yeah
and that was that was just that was
terrible
and so we changed the guidance you know
we should have we should have put the
updated guidance in in the first place
and said to
everybody it is okay to have a small
number of members of your family
at every funeral of course you can
socially distance at a funeral so long
as there aren't too many people there
and you're a boy
yeah well i've talked about i've talked
about um
i talked about that and and i've you
know it really affected me actually
watching him being buried by men in
hazmat suits
rather than with his loving family
nearby
and that's one example of something that
we
we should have done differently first
time around what other mistakes have you
made
well off the top of your head i don't
know there's there'll be a time for
reviews you seem quite weary
do you think well um
i kind of think that looking back i'm
not going to be bombastic
about it i'd rather i'd far rather
listen and because all that matters is
getting the response right
going forward yeah but you i mean you
you were poorly weren't you
and you had covered 19 yourself even
when you went back to work i could see
that you were still
poorly and yet you've had to do it
because if not you
then who would have um taken
the nation to where we are now it you've
had a massive responsibility on your
shoulders and i'm not blowing wind up
your scope because i give you a hard
time a lot
but you know it has been incredibly
difficult for you to to what extent do
you
that burden of responsibility does it
weigh you down you know
lots of people ask me this question and
it doesn't
it i don't think of it that way i don't
feel that
um because i feel highly motivated to
get it right
and that includes constantly listening
to the accusations that you get and
listening to the
criticisms and saying well where are
they where have they got a point
and what can we learn from it and you
know i just i get up in the morning
and i think what can i do today to try
to get this country's
the best possible response and then i
work
um on that all day and
then i go to bed and i get up and do the
same and you know occasionally i get a
few
hours off um this weekend i managed to
play
um i managed to play frisbee in the park
with
my kids um and so take some exercise
that's okay with social
yes it is because it's exercise in the
park got exercise in the park exercise
is one of the important reasons that
people can go out
um and um there was it was a
an and you know so i do try to take a
couple of hours off
uh at the weekend but it's you know
you've just got to
you've just got to do everything you can
to get the response right so i feel
highly motivated actually
are you fully better now yeah yeah yeah
yeah um
fortunately it was only mild i mean gosh
other people have had it not
seen me well for for about 48 hours it
was really really tough
um i had a very sore throat so i
couldn't drink or eat
for 24 hours 48 hours maybe um
and i had the aching in the muscles that
lots of people talk about but
fortunately it didn't seem to get onto
my lungs so
my breathing wasn't particularly a
problem um
and and i was tired i was tired
um and then but fortunately it was only
it was relatively short and then i
bounced out of it quite relatively fast
were you surprised at how badly
affected the prime minister was yeah
because both of us got it at about the
same time sure
and um i i was within a
within four or five days i felt like i
was i was i was getting much better
and within a week i was back out at the
at the uh podium at the press conference
and
the and i talked him all the way through
it and
in the first few days we seemed to be
very much on a par
and then i just got better
and he didn't and it was that was um
you know it was it was it was strange
because i just thought well
you know i'm getting better he'll get
better as well and then
then he didn't and then it does seem to
hit people sometimes a second time
because then it came and um you know he
um suddenly he went downhill and it was
quite sudden how he went downhill
the second time we all saw the videos
that were out in the public domain
and him coming out to clap for carers on
the thursday night and looking like a
ghost
and um it was uh you know
it it obviously well you know we all
know it hit him very hard i mean he was
close to death
by his own admission we have now got
the highest death rate in europe how can
that be
how were we just not prepared no i think
i think we've got to be very cautious
with these these data
i think we've got to be really careful
in how we describe it
because um you've got to take a lot of
things into account so firstly
we're we're one of the biggest countries
in europe and that matters
so there are smaller countries which
naturally will have a lower death rate
because they've
the like got fewer principles with those
countries even italy yeah so spain and
italy for instance
don't include deaths outside of hospital
in their figures
um we didn't used to because it's harder
to count deaths in the community and in
care homes and we now do um and so
you'll have seen
um early last week there was a rise in
the number of published
deaths here and that's because we
include
all deaths from coronavirus not just
those in hospital
so you know spain and italy are smaller
countries
and they don't include all deaths in
their figures so
you've got to be very careful about
essentially comparing
like with like if you talk to the
statisticians and the chief medical
officer
what they say is that it's only
afterwards looking back
and looking at the total number of
people who've died during the peak
compared to the normal number because
you've also got to take into account the
age profile and factors like
uh obesity because it does seem to be a
link between obesity
and uh and
um i i wouldn't put those words into his
own
mouth i'd leave you ask him the question
and see how he responds
you've got to make sure you're comparing
uh apples with apples
and the way to make that sort of
comparison i'm advised
is you've got to look at the impact of
you've got to look at the
total number of the of deaths
over the period compared that to a
normal year
and that is the that's the way to make
that sort of comparison
we're over uh the peak at least for now
is
is what we are being told let's let's uh
end if we may with um
a final viewer's question about the
tracking app uh trial
underway uh on the isle of wight and
this is what david is saying if the
trials for the new
are not successful do you have a plan b
uh yes we do we'll
we'll improve the app um and um
we'll we'll look at doing it in a
different way
and we'll increase the number of human
contact tracers because the app is only
part of actually a whole
program the testing the human contact
tracing
and then the technology it's all about
tracing the virus
and following the virus as it spreads
security issues
even today in the guardian they're
talking about security issues and
uh people not wanting to get involved
not signing up because
they don't necessarily want people to
know where they are all the time well
i just asked mr ferguson well we
wouldn't know where people are all the
time so those
i've seen those concerns and they are
wrong they don't under
they they are not based on what's
happening in the app the point is in the
app that the data is stored on your own
phone until you choose to go to the nhs
to get a test uh if you've got positive
symptoms
so you know i think i i have you know
i've seen
articles about this and questions about
this but but they're based on a
misunderstanding
of what the app is what the app does and
to prove the point we've published the
source code of the app so anybody can go
and have a look at how the app
works uh and how it protects your
privacy
while also critically being so important
for uh for for the health of the nation
it protects you
it protects the people who you're close
to it protects the community
we've taken those privacy concerns into
account in its design
i haven't yet seen a critique based on
privacy that is accurate
or based on an actual understanding of
what the app does so
if anybody's proposing to make the has
those concerns or is proposing to write
about them i would suggest that they go
and look at what the app actually does
before doing so
because if you are spreading those sorts
of those sorts of stories
and discouraging people from taking it
from downloading the app
then what you're actually doing is
making it harder for us as a community
to fight this virus
so i'm being quite robust in my response
to these critiques because we have taken
the concerns into account we have an
ethics advisory board
we of course will be publishing the uh
the data protection impact assessment
and all of the
um information around this but we've
published the source code so you can see
what the app does and if you download
the app
then the data that of who you are in
close contact with stays on your phone
and it doesn't go to us until you
until you come to us and say i've got
the symptoms i need a positive test
and so it's i can give people that very
significant reassurance and actually
contrary to some of the media around
this um
on the isle of wight where it is
actually in operation
um there have been two surveys of who
would be
up for downloading the app and one came
that came through saying 80 of people
were going to download it and the other
came through saying 75
of people were going to download it and
that is the sort of take-up figures that
i
expected and very much uh hope for and
we'll and we'll see
okay just before we let you go we've
kept you longer than anticipated we
appreciate you uh spending more time to
take our viewers questions
final thought last time we were in the
studio together here was
february time right neither of us had
any comprehension
of what was to come what this uh
wretched disease was going to do this
virus going to do not only to the uk
but to everyone around the world i'm not
sure about that oh really did you know
i was very worried about it yeah yeah
and you know i first found out about
this
but if you knew in february why were you
not stop compiling what we needed we
were
we were why were the tests not available
we were building the testing capability
yes
but we still didn't have enough time to
do it because it moves so quickly that's
what you're saying that's right you know
we invented the test
in uh january in february we got
the number of tests up to two thousand
in march we multiplied that by five
times
ten thousand and then obviously we i set
the
well the germans started with this
enormous diagnostics industry
but if you look at other countries
around the world we're we're miles ahead
on testing
and we're now one of the world leaders
um it's true that germany has a very
high
um a very high capacity about the same
as ours so we've basically caught up
with
germany that started with this massive
capability and the americans are also
ahead we're miles ahead of south korea
now
absolutely so so um i i first found out
about
uh we didn't know it was covered 19 it
wasn't called that
at the start of january yeah um right
december wasn't it 31st of december the
31st of december is when the
wh the chinese um
admitted to it and then and i found out
at the end of that at the end of that
week on the friday of that week
and i started having meetings in the
department we discussed it
from the right from the start of january
and put in place
we you know we had the uh the plans but
the plans were
in advance were for a flu as opposed to
a coronavirus so we had to
adjust them now but i've been working on
this full time since
since long before um it became a subject
of national issue and in fact i remember
some prime minister's questions in sort
of february
certainly there thinking i was sitting
there in the house commons all these
questions about all the other things
that matter in life
i'm thinking nobody's asking about the
single biggest issue that's about to
come and hit us
really and it did yeah and why do you
think that was why why was it well
because it wasn't it was
it was it was a it was a sort of health
issue that was going on in china
as opposed to um and i was
briefing cabinet and now he's doing
statements to parliament and people are
asking
was the prime minister not listening no
the prime minister was heavily involved
yeah i told i told him right at the
start no
night's holiday didn't he one of his
comments no he didn't no is that not
true
i know it's not true so i look they've
been
you know they're they're people what are
stories in the press that aren't true
uh that i think you're referring to a
particular
investigation by a sunday newspaper that
was absolutely riddled with errors and
part of what you know part that's all
about the history what matters
is what happens going forward okay final
thought before i let you go finally um
what you're most looking forward to when
lockdown ends
going to suffolk so i've been stuck in
london
and yeah i i i i haven't been to suffolk
to my constituency
for you know more than a month probably
two months now
i can still i can still do my job as
local mp thanks to email and phones
look i'll just get getting out to the
countryside getting lungfuls of fresh
air
it's good to talk to your health
secretary thank you very much indeed for
taking the time i know on behalf of our
viewers
we really appreciate it